all right here we go good evening
everyone and welcome to the debut of one
nation i'm brian kilmeade we have a
packed show for you tonight got fox news
contributor charlie hurt some would say
he's right to my immediate left and
former nassau county executive laura
curran here together in studio to talk
to you about what matters most and the
mayor of keeve joins us to discuss the
escalating tensions with ukraine and
russia and the phone call from president
biden curt shilling his first interview
since being snubbed for the tenth time
in the hall of fame even though he has
the numbers to be in cooperstown plus
miracle on ice captain mike carruzzioni
and foreign policy expert ian bremmer
together to talk about whether we should
be going to the beijing of the beijing
olympics at all and the one and only
kennedy is here for the first ever in
the history of television news duel but
first i want to share with you the goal
of the show that you're seeing for the
very first time so our journey together
is fantastic each and every week let me
tell you what you're in for as you know
it's a challenging time for our country
passion's running high for both
republicans and democrats and
independents maybe at your kitchen table
so on this show we're going to strive to
push party ames behind us and put first
what the nation needs most and that is
patriotic passion over emotional party
division can you imagine now it's my
hope to analyze the issues in depth with
expert guests who might even be smarter
than me again except for charlie hurt
we're going to work each and every week
to put things in perspective with the
ultimate goal of bringing the country
together i'm not going to yell at you
instead i'm going to fight with you on
the issues that matter most to you and
are the best interest of the country at
large i'm not interested in scoring
political points you do that during the
week we're going to have conversations
and dare i say we're going to solve some
problems and entertain and inform i've
done play by play and sold out sports
arenas i've done stand-up and small
sports bars and for the last 25 years
covered all the major events this
country has taken on right here on the
fox news channel much of which in this
very studio my aim is to bring that
knowledge and diverse experience to you
each and every week always remember we
are one nation so meet me here every
saturday night at eight o'clock
sound good hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else